mesdames messieurs
alors aujourd'hui je parlerai en
français et du français
je me présente je m'appelle nous a dit
que je suis doctorante au laboratoire
d'eric à la faculté des lettres et des
sciences humaines d'el jadida
depuis quelques années je m'intéresse à
l'enseignement du français et
particulièrement de l'oral prenant 10 de
la compétence à produire à l'oral vous
avez sûrement tv pourquoi une telle
recherche pour la même raison
quand maroc ces dernières années on ne
retient que des rapports négatifs
concernant la performance notre système
éducatif
oui et compris l'enseignement des
langues officielles et étrangères le
résultat est encore plus visible plus
alarmant du cefrio
quand on parle du français je m'explique
quand on observe que des menaces on
trouve certains élèves qui arrive à
répéter dans un volume horaire qui
dépasse les mêmes choses
deux mille cinq cents heures de cours de
français
ce même groupe avait à l'université se
trouve incapable de parler français ou
du moins avec plusieurs lacunes
sérieuses laquelle vous allez voir est
en fait ces résultats ces résultats sont
en menaçant pour un pays tel que le
maroc
oui parce que le maroc est considéré
comme un pays francophone est il qu'on
accorde un statut privilégié pour la
langue française
d'ailleurs je suis sûr que vous l'avez
déjà constatées aujourd'hui la médecine
française à la ville et à l'oral se voit
un atout important voire décisif pour
poursuivre des études supérieures pour
plus de productivité plus de pertinence
en faisant de la recherche scientifique
et pour un avenir assuré
et donc la gelée par une insertion
professionnelle
mais tout se passe l'ime classe pourquoi
tellement amoureux n'ont en général
n'arrivent pas à produire en france est
arrivée à l'université en 60 et
observation de pinasses il est de ces
apprenants s'est avéré que nous apparaît
bookeen que mon nom
paroles très belle très strictes puis
réduite dans le temps perçu par là les
endroits non marocains vous n'avez pas
l'occasion de s'exprimer en français et
je remets en question
je remets en question cette situation
parce que le fait de ne pas donner
l'opportunité à un moment de parier en
france est d'expérimenter la langue
française fait que un jour tu ne mourras
voir les français
je voulais qu'ils intéressent à moi
avantagé à cet enseignement de la langue
française et pour moi c'était sur les
images les oeuvres d'art aller les
intéristes et parce qu'ils offraient de
la couleur et forme le contenu m
intrigue et parfois c'est là c'est
toujours intéressant de découvrir des
formes artistiques
parce que ça nous rend perplexe on
découvre on est séduit
on est charmé et la promo en nous le
désir dire et c'est ce que je
chez empreinte chez apprenant qu'il
n'arrivait pas à parler français
le dire et donc ce que j'essaie de faire
c'est d'exposer et de les ont quittés en
glace n'était pas vraiment eu de
stimuler un enseignement au rail et j'ai
essayé de les inviter en classe
l'enseignant dans ce cas ne se focalise
pas seulement sur le savoir enseigner
départ d'un juste la langue mais avec la
langue
une arrivée à transmettre autre chose et
donc enseignants se dépasser il devenait
médiateur le plus important dans cette
situation c'est qu'il devait élever
apprenant à parler interagir et enée
l'interaction les aider à participer une
classe e
les apprenants en les invités dans un
musée à observer à décrire a jugé à
donner un jugement subjectif adolescents
9 a donné un commentaire
à raconter des histoires à travers
l'oeuvre d'art après interpréter et
dames et messieurs
on était vraiment une surprise pour la
seule raison que ces apprenants qui
l'invitera à parler français
quand on leur a donné l'occasion de
parler français il produisit il
produisait quelque chose d'amusant
mais donc très intéressant les
commentaires les interprétations
concernant des tableaux de peinture de
monet de picasso sabado d'asie vincent
van gogh ou deux photographes français
célèbre oui mesdames et messieurs vous
produisez c'était des participations
personnel cinq buts hier mais qui les
aider à stimuler toutes les facultés
toutes les modalités qui devait avoir
les sens
la voix la créativité des positions
laissant station autrement dit
instant rendu compte que l'on pouvait
attendre
oui mais autrement qu'à revoir fin tir
créer expérimenter la langue pouvait les
aider à stimuler ce qu'on ne pouvait pas
des casiers
c'est la raison pour laquelle si on
n'arrive pas à nous faire on doit
changer
essayer autre chose mais de le faire
toutes officiellement ce qu'on possède
et je pense que c'est ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui j'avais un blocage en
dessous du bocage la page blanche sur ce
qu'on appelle la plage blanche j'avais
vu rien
ce que j'essaie de faire c'est de
retenir de me remémorer on peut les mots
clés que j'avais et d'essayer de le
restructurer pour expliquer et donc les
dames et messieurs
n'hésitez pas quand vous savez quand
vous ne pouvez pas le faire essayer de
le faire autrement et chers enseignants
n'hésitez pas aussi à donner la
possibilité à vos apprenants de créer et
de produire car souvent vous serez
surpris
merci